you ever take my fart store with louie
no
bad it's embarrassing but what i was
opening for him we're in the four
seasons watching some movie it's me list
and i think lynn copplets or somebody
but we're all hanging out i'm sitting on
his bed he's on the desk somebody else
is at the chair and i go wait wait wait
wait wait
and he goes dude what the [ __ ]
and i was like
i thought you'd love that it's a joke
it's a fart i figured he would like love
a fart joke and he hated he was like
you're farting in here get out what are
you doing i was like
i wouldn't saw him on the daily show say
farts are funny exactly
that is hilarious yeah
you fraud
i farted i was a classic just that i
think i think now women know what they
have to do to get him to not do what he
did
that's how you get about the room
that's great that's hilarious man
he hated
i mean crushed i was like oh my god it
was like the first night of opening i
thought i was going to be off the tour i
think a loud fart is still funny let's
go quiet farts
you ever wear someone in the car on the
road and it's like the worst and you're
like dude why would you do this to me
but but like the announcing and then
check this out for some reason still
gets me i've never been prouder of a
comedic moment and he shut it down the
guy at the highest height of comedy shot
me down that's brutal
you farted at the world's most liked at
the time comedian yes and you're like
check this out
and he's just like why yeah
i list pulled me aside after what was
that i'm like i don't know he's like
that was bad i'm like that was bad
yeah i mean louis hated it did the list
ever say that to louie
i don't think so
i mean
where is he on that friendship
that that he's fine with
but yeah it was a it was a big bummer i
was i was here to hear i felt like i was
too tall damn yeah that is [ __ ] dude
why would you do that that's funny i
thought i had him i was like oh this is
going to win him over baby
not you know who loves farts you know
die you do a fart she will [ __ ] the bed
as michelle wolf really loves a fart
anytime anywhere church funeral gas
chamber whatever fart it up chill she'll
feel too close to the gas chamber yeah
yeah
that's a bad name for a place to fart
dude that's hilarious that you did that
and it didn't work out at all yeah i
took a risk
that's a [ __ ] risk i would i was like
this is in the pocket
i'm gonna be uh i'm gonna be uh opening
on every every date and quite the
opposite
more to see guys join the patreon right
now at patreon.com we might be drunk get
on the after party i think i just broke
this
there you go
you get emails tell us your wrecks your
jokes your drinks we'll open boxes
you're missing out folks all the good
stuff's on the patreon tell a friend